and speaking of china i want to take you
back to something we covered on this
show now as three months ago
over the past two years chinese
nationals have begun buying up tens of
thousands of acres of farmland in the
state of oklahoma
while they've been doing so in a number
of states oklahoma has become their
go-to state for these purchases given
the economic and the national security
ramifications here
congress should get involved
well now they are my next guest senator
tom cotton and his colleague tommy
tuberville introduced a bill this week
that would ban the ccp and anyone
associated with the ccp
from buying up american land and it's
not just the oklahoma farmland i told
you about according to the national
association of realtors
chinese investors were one of the top
foreign purchasers of u.s land spending
a record 6.1 billion last year just on
existing homes senator cotton joins me
now
senator i can hear the um the
libertarians out there saying well what
what's the big deal here china's
engaging in
you know capitalism they're buying up
land that's driving up prices why isn't
that good for the economy
well our libertarian thought is very
helpful in guiding tax policy and
regulatory policy here in the united
states ronald reagan understood that but
in a world of borders it doesn't work
quite so well borders that are open on
our border with mexico or we have
chinese influence crossing into our
border from mainland china and trying or
letting china buy up our farmland or our
food companies is a massive strategic
mistake
look the simple facts are this china
cannot feed itself the united states can
not only feed our own citizen but feed
much of the world thanks to the
productivity of our farmers and our
ranchers why would we ever want to
surrender that huge strategic advantage
to china
well gordon chang pointed out that and
this was recently he wrote the piece
saying that
individuals you know that actually are
allowed to
you know
purchase this land
the national intelligence law of of
china
that
they actually have to be part of the you
know chinese network of of the national
intelligence law
and they require every chinese national
entity to commit acts of espionage if
the regime demands so it's like china
views
their foreign nationals whether they're
here to buy land or here to be involved
in some business
to track activities of americans and
businesses while they're here if asked
correct
yeah that's right laura i mean china is
not america china is a communist country
and in america if an american citizen
wants to buy a farm in canada or buy a
timeshare condo in mexico they can do
that they don't have to ask permission
of our government but in china if you
want to get out of the country if you
want to take your money out of the
country then you in effect have to ask
for permission from the chinese
communist party
and to do their bidding if called upon
that's why we should simply stop these
kinds of purchases of farmlands or food
companies or from chinese companies
building new food companies here in
america like they're trying to do
outside the grand forks air force base
in north dakota doing the lord knows
what else in proximity to that base we
should just stop it it should not be
allowed
senator thank you so much hey sean
hannity here hey click here to subscribe
to fox news youtube page and catch our
hottest interviews and most compelling
analysis you will not get it anywhere
else